il vend le plus lu dans le monde avec
100 millions d'exemplaires vendus dans
un instant nous rejoindront en direct de
cannes l'écrivain brésilien paulo coelho
qui est venu y présenter son dernier
livre car l'intrigué se déroule
justement en plein festival
l'auteur y décrit un monde de paillettes
totalement superficiel nous allons y
revenir mais les stars elles mêmes que
pense-t-elle de cette atmosphère si
particulière
réponse avec sabine gorny et nathalie
berthier la croisette nombril du monde
pendant 12 jours lieu de promotion idéal
pour un romancier qui a choisi en 400
pages dans résumé l'incroyable
superficialité mais rassurez-vous paulo
ici comme vous personne n'est dupe c'est
des bateaux l'elliott les belles-filles
la fête quoi que l'on en a pas beaucoup
le temps de faire la fête mais et puis
c'est le je pense le glamour à le
glamour sarine avec en avant marche tous
les jours une heure pendant lesquels on
joue à ta vu je suis la plus belle mare
aux baies rouges comme le tapis sophie
vanité des vanités c'est pour mieux
impressionner la pellicule le cinéma est
un art de vanité je suis désolé mais
cinéma c'est comme toute forme d'art
d'ailleurs c'est très très utile à
soigner
les tourments les crises et toutes ces
choses là franchement n'irai pas mon
village de goumois le cinéma thérapie
d'accord mais dans les suites des
palaces transformer un coffre-fort
business is business
les maisons de luxe drague à touba
mannequin et actrice transformer en
objet publicitaire pardon ici on dit
ambassadrice oui j'ai rit un peu de
linkedin tout ça non forcément c'est un
peu moi c'est un côté glamour des et
diamants les bijoux mais fédérer n'est
qu'une fois par an et on est très
privilégié canton et la commune car il
ya ceux qui en sont et ce qu'ils n'en
sont pas mondiaux un autographe un
sourire une place une invitation cannes
forteresse du cinéma impossible à
pénétrer à moins d'en avoir les clés de
tout le temps qu sud quelque chose
l'idée des endroits exclusive de
l'espace vip du vigile de la barrière d
en être ou pas du beau carton du bon
badge c'est ça qui est un peu du maître
chien du truc de la sécurité on ne
comprend pas très bien parce que les ans
droite est donc tout à fait à l'image un
peu arrogante méchante petite et grande
humiliation strass paillettes et prison
matière romanesque à souhait pour un
auteur lui aussi est victime de son
succès et en direct de cannes nous
rejoignons donc paulo